[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
whatever the [ __ ] we want
oh we finally finally got invited to
Tim's house to have the the food the
Thai food it was it was like it was like
three years we were we were [ __ ] it
sounded like you were rubbing it in her
face that's it did it I didn't take it
that way so let me show you the thought
process yeah but you guys are
emotionally [ __ ] so we get why you
didn't you just said Paige I was saying
it I looked into her eyes and I saw pain
but I wanted to complete the same thing
so I said oh I will say this though it
was [ __ ] delicious you know what
happened it was the best of my life it
was [ __ ] delicious and but I will
tell you this to make you feel better
we all got mosquito bites I did not I
got bit like six times out of nowhere
yeah good the next day the biggest [ __ ]
of my life because I ate so much [ __ ]
food you know we like that even more so
like I ate all that food and that's
diplomat there dude I woke up I woke up
that morning still full then I trained
yesterday and I had a cold brew yeah
this close to [ __ ] on my shoes
[ __ ] what do you oh [ __ ] yes I did it
was like batshit like I was literally
driving and then it just hit me it went
boom and it would like to put just
literally this yeah like this cut the
poop was like hello [ __ ] on her ankle
although I was this close to shooting on
my [ __ ] in my pants
cuz I could feel it just go for hole
right and I saw a target all the way I
ran inside and you know like right when
I was by pulling my pants down to poop
already started coming up and I barely
miss my pants did you spray the toilet
I felt you couldn't see water no did you
hit the seat in the [ __ ] wall
but it was so much leader this is you
could not see water dude there was so
much poop that came out but I weighed
myself after 218 babies what do you mean
you can't see water like we need poor
too much cereal you know can't see them
it was like like it was that much food
so everything I ate there was out of my
body it was good though I tasted [ __ ]
like what do you call it when you get an
ice-cream and then you put a spresso
shot it was a chocolate off oh god all
right there but I came at that bathroom
to my [ __ ] face was like pale well I
wasn't exactly
it was wild I never ever in my life poop
that much in one instance crazy Thai
chilies and cold brew I could teach you
how sometimes I have my cheat meals so
I'll stop by like 3 different places I
go to the Hat and I'll get a pastrami
sandwich and a chili cheeseburger and a
large fries large fries then you go to
Taco Bell get me black for tacos and
then you go to McDonald's we get like
two pigments and whatever and then the
order of boba and then you make a root
beer float at home when you eat all of
that next day that poop is [ __ ] huge
how can you eat all of that you're
hungry in one Sanny
I've been hungry sometimes eats like
he's [ __ ] about the hibernate in
shape
Wow you guys do separate bathrooms no no
you're the same one
oh I [ __ ] on the floor on the the lower
bathroom what's up you [ __ ] on the floor
I told you it's like I had David I had
David's problem that one time we're like
all just running in the house and then
you're just you're just squeezing as
hard as you can to not let it out but
before you're even like before you even
know you're able to reach the toilet
when you pull your pants down
it just started flying on the floor
ready it was like you know in the
helicopter and a movie was like it was
like that was a cop up up up up on the
floor on the bottom of the toilet bowl
on the table on the toilet seat and then
finally I feel bad for you geo you got
two babies in the house five yeah
all the [ __ ] was outside of the toilet
like he presents it to you guys like he
was probably was really sad I was the
smell like [ __ ] I forgot how much the
water does to your [ __ ] oh dude because
when you take a dump and it goes in the
water like half the smells good I highly
recommend everyone take your [ __ ]
outdoors not like where you live like in
the wild oh did you do that one campaign
I did and then that's when I realized
that the water makes a huge difference
did you get dirt thrown yeah just
animals it feels very liberating I felt
so bad for pooping something that big I
actually just bought something random at
Target had a guilt I bought a spray
bottle for my succulents it was like a
doll or something I was like dude I got
it I got it
you know they got undercover security at
Target already yeah so we were buying
something for whatever orbed
target yeah you gotta just stop that we
were buying some outs on a picture with
a what is blink right now is just a
brake conveyor belt I know we bought
something it's good rolling but they
were buying something and we see this
couple go and we thought they were
shady-looking already because they look
like [ __ ] be outward and really wise
Rd outward people like walking around in
the north
world and then we see them go towards
the the little beeper things the minute
they cross to people with red shirts
come and grab them and then the four
other people and just regular clothes
they're all part of target [ __ ] and then
I realized they all have the FBI here
think they all grabbed them and picked
them up and then the girl was trying to
uh just trying to scream like we should
screaming like rape or some [ __ ] like
that all right oh wow Mary's [ __ ] up
anyway she's trying to insinuate sexual
harassment
and the two guys just have our arms sure
that was like oh you're hurting me but I
can tell she's trying to insinuate rape
mm-hmm and then they drag them into that
that's so could you tell me what
actually the crazy thing is like I work
that target in the security guards would
never touch the people so that's pretty
[ __ ] that's next level yeah because
you're not supposed to touch them oh
that has like six people came they just
block the doorway and just tell them
stop grab them yeah yeah maybe they're
cops
maybe those 100 yeah yeah he grabbed him
for sure ah good they just look like
hipsters like really but they look like
they were like on something like the guy
look like [ __ ] Diane were like a
[ __ ] I would just like if
somebody's stealing like small [ __ ] from
Target
I wouldn't even try to arrest them I
just socially shamed them
[ __ ] good god dude that's all you're
stealing you [ __ ] loser how poor are
you poor character from shady agents
pick up in high school there was this
dude named Xavier and this this will try
to steal like a beaker in like our chem
class and I just was like beef babe and
that bull hated my guts
just because he was so embarrassed you
know it's just why are you stealing a
beaker bro dr. Biber done the same thing
and you would kick my ass I thought it
was tied really no my bad bro people get
away with a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] like if
they do get away like thousands of
dollars oh [ __ ] because the people that
they're looking for though or like you
would are stealing like you know over a
hundred dollars worth of things cuz if
if they are following them for like a
bag of chips
I think that's [ __ ] stupid on the
Securities job but the the technology is
so [ __ ] good like they could zoom in
and this is like when I worked at Target
so this is like ancient times like 10
years ago like more than that but they
could zoom in in the parking lot like
let's say your car's all in the parking
lot right they could get the camera and
then they could take a picture of your
[ __ ] license plate from far away yeah
so then what they'll do is they'll
follow the guys and in like let's say
they just keep running or walking away
they could get that camera and embalm
didn't whatever car they get into well
target didn't catch me accidentally
stealing a wallet so they didn't do
their job how did Josh and I still alone
cuz you know those those magic wallets
where you flip it open and it grabs the
money
oh so I was playing with it the whole
time and I was just like distracted and
then I walked out and then it was in my
car for like a few months or I thought
how long it was and then I was asking
whose wallet it was and it wasn't good
but it clicked in my head that I stole
it accidentally because I was just
playing with it cause it was like a fun
toy wait how did you like pay and
everything the whole time you're playing
with it I didn't buy anything okay I
just left my name by now I was playing
with it I was like oh that's kind of
cool and then I had it in my car
they found I stole you are pretty
absent-minded suffice yeah so if they
able to tackle me for that I'll be so
upset know what's going on yeah I
freaked out easy dude I miss stealing I
[Laughter]
don't know the thrill of the steal but I
quit doing that [ __ ] this feels I had
girlfriends I would shop Lutron all the
time and every time I went with them I
would always be like alright we're gonna
do this let's do it and then we'll do it
I'm like no why did we do it I feel so
guilty for some reason I feel like when
girls steal it's like to turn them on my
biggest [ __ ] masturbate in the car
right after the newest I really what
girls do it's like exciting for them
it's like yes these are masturbating the
Kathi's oh [ __ ] his car almost got
stolen over the weekend oh shut up yeah
by who I don't know yeah your windows
your nature thugs someone tried to break
in and they screwed all the key holes in
the car like yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] get
in the car [ __ ] they bust it up so much
yeah my car was next to him not a
scratch do you have chemo I was worried
about my car - I was like damn it
scratch it oh thank god your car like
significantly nicer than everyone no
it's just a Corolla 2016 Corolla does
your car key holes nobody knows why
maybe he got something against keyholes
no but Chris has his Miata there they
could've stolen his Miata I think what
what it was is since I have SUV yeah I
blocked one side visitors his car was at
the very end and it was deep into the
parking lot so I think what the what the
culprits did is parked their other car
in between my car in his car and then
they were able to [ __ ] with it all day
because if anyone were to come and try
to park they wouldn't see whoever was
[ __ ] with his car basically what
we're saying is Toyota sponsor us that's
how sturdy your cars are great
if you want to stupid-ass the trunk
keyhole all of them so they're really
maybe it was like a practice working for
them nobody I don't know how much is all
that gonna cost
it's a couple grand because no insurance
covering most of it so they said that
for me to change the key it affects the
internal wiring of the car so they have
to change the electronics in the car as
well too so it's not just that it's not
just the keyhole yeah that's why if you
just have a regular Honda Element nobody
ever touches your car no one cares about
it's almost embarrassing to break into
they open the door and just throw their
trash in there actually what happened
was somebody broke into my Honda Element
and actually left me money to get a new
car oh they're like I'm sorry like that
I love that card even homeless people
feel bad no they won't even sleep in it
don't make fun of my car you know what
common cars like like the average cars
that are like those get stolen the most
that's what you're saying yeah yeah
Corolla Camry civil parts remember the
that time was to call when that Civic Si
came out yeah it was the most jack car
town they would get like the emblem or
they would just get broken into because
they it had like a weird thing that was
[ __ ] up they made it easy to break
into that car so everybody was jealous
of sports version right yeah when I was
going to on a church retreat they left
somebody just bought that Civic s I
forgot who was I think was my friend
Robin but he left it in the parking lot
somebody came into the church parking
lot Jack this card when he came back
gone yeah welcome God didn't help God
was just like mmm you got a stupid s car
good luck that's a lesson for you yeah
you steal from a church that's pretty
bad that's bad karma right there dad did
I ever steal from the church probably
really I went to private school for two
years I'm done I'm the dogs doing my
stealing face how's the hatred did that
I was afraid of the wrath of God i ben
stiller since I was six still forever
don't be proud of
I wasn't problem just letting you know
how factual it is I accidentally stole
chocolate can I ate that [ __ ]
cuz I was like I
gonna make it go to waste did you throw
up out of guilt
nope I just said well the insurance will
take care of it
a couple years ago this wasn't y-you
know what I spent like $300 on [ __ ]
groceries so I'm gonna justify I was
just too lazy to drive back to [ __ ]
food lad and say hey brah you got a
drive back to food laughs take off your
shirt and throw your shoes off and walk
in when just board shorts
yeah you see to match the crowd hey brah
like I prepared a monocle bro stop doing
that I know I'm going September where
are you going you ready got the tickets
in the buy the ticket yeah I can't wait
that was gonna [ __ ] no I said I'm
probably not gonna do nothing this time
to deal of [ __ ] should we take Tiger to
Hawaii
what do you like September yeah I think
you guys are in oh no you guys are you
know francais yeah oh maybe we're
thinking maybe uh now the French like
Riviera side are you bringing a tiger
inside of France with you you gotta give
him a little beret and [ __ ] paint
mustache around him yes this little
passport already and everything Oh cute
I pictured a little vest with his mouth
open you see that those big is definite
like this our thumbs are in the picture
does you have to hold them like this so
just like those watch the ball yeah
that's so [ __ ] funny BEC no child so
damn cute I know I got a visitor more
often I think what a blinking you're
growing so that just got his driver's
license yeah the [ __ ] I missed although
it comes in now oh he started showing me
his like oh [ __ ] he's gonna show some
look long his leg hair he's like mommy
now I have hairier my leg
like we look to be the star shape you
know just let it grow out I have two
mustaches one for this nose and under
this nose too he has if he's gonna get a
hairy back in a hairy chest
I mean hairy back no you doesn't have a
lot of justified then I don't know but
it's pretty come standard when you buy
Mexicans it comes down that's right it's
well carpeted yeah it's pretty hi are
you the [ __ ] ambassador of Mexicans I
bought many what what bought many what
does that mean that's one of the things
we go to the Mexican dealerships they're
so proud of how well carpeted there can
I introduce you to this 2017 Mexican
company I wish you guys could see how
the green [ __ ] in between his teeth
there's so much green [ __ ] Chinese
broccoli oh yeah yeah it's distracting
hilarious
you can literally talk the most [ __ ] as
much as you want but when there's
something stuck in your teeth it just
destroys everything [ __ ] cut back
[ __ ] hey why don't you get that [ __ ]
broccoli snip now you keep losing [ __ ]
god damn it I was doing so well yeah it
negates everything you know what makes
people not evil anymore watching them
eat yeah it has to be normal food though
it can't be like eating a human being or
something yeah and it's not taking a
[ __ ] I think taking a [ __ ] makes every
evil person look like very vulnerable
really maybe yeah yeah like what 20
looks [ __ ] badass you know like all
the toilets on the robot show those are
pretty badass I won't sleep you're still
like this you know I would say like a
desert boba drink and mash like eating
something like mashed potatoes or like a
strawberry shortcake like a dessert
right like but can you imagine a [ __ ]
straight mafia eating a [ __ ]
strawberry shortcake pops a coffee
yeah or like or like a um like a being
sued with all the [ __ ] fruits around
it [ __ ] shave ice the big Asian car
there's an ice cream cone alone that's
fine well a three color pink ice cream
cone just licking that [ __ ]
yeah I can picture Joe Pesci in that
[ __ ] he's still some kind of gangster
though yeah you don't want to take them
off yeah
put the shave ice a big one especially
with the raping this way that's pretty
thug my mom would never let me hold it
like this cuz she's like it's only for
hooligans oh really
hold it like this like a you eat yeah
what the [ __ ] gonna be a what yeah no
I'm talking about like this were you oh
like you're [ __ ] in jail is [ __ ] yeah
yeah how you supposed to use a spoon I'm
thinking now I don't know you do it the
right way
oh it's just like this or whatever good
like a pen on us but not really I think
so I don't remember
I don't know I judge people on how they
cut their meat how if they if they're
not doing it with the left with the fork
and the left depending on what your
dominant and doing it this way you have
people like this and yes my mom does
that [ __ ] pisses me off did where she
stabs it go like this and they should do
like that I should eat it like that and
I'm like mom if you do that one more
time I'm gonna snap your little [ __ ]
cavewoman you're supposed to switch
every time you know that that the real
whale is like that I don't do it I just
have the fork on my right hand the whole
time so it's easier for foam Bulbul and
Korean Korean food there's really really
whole food that you eat everything is
already in small pieces or in a stew so
there's no reason to have a fat piece of
meat that's an American thing oh she's
not used to cutting just is no she was
like what is this like why isn't it
pre-cut for me you know so for her she's
just like okay
you know it's more comfortable for cuz
this is kind of weird - nah dude she's a
natural-born killer
like who [ __ ] stab [ __ ] like that
comfortably something on friggin she's
loosen it didn't come to me though cuz
I'm a natural-born
stupid-ass rule you go like this way
it's like this so you have to come with
your right hold it with your life and
then you [ __ ] switch it over and then
you go like this I hate it and then you
do it again and you got to do it again
who came up with that [ __ ] rule
I just have the fork I'm alright and
then the whole time that's weird you
come with your left hand I could cut
with my left yeah I cut my right you
could do it just trust me if if if
you're right-handed and you could beat
off with your I hat and then when the
[ __ ] mouse came out and then you're
[ __ ] cooking around with the mouse
and you [ __ ] jack off with your left
hand you can learn that you can learn
this never touching your computer now I
just come on the [ __ ] trackpad do
that either use my phone call the police
for me I can't wipe it with alcohol
strips
[Music]